it's software weighs in on the doom
eternal soundtrack drama ei play
announced for June and are we going to
see halo infinite gameplay this week no
we're not I'm Lucy and may the force be
with you
it's Star Wars day the doom eternal
soundtrack beef is getting spicier
composer Mick Gordon distanced himself
from the project after the soundtrack
released with fans noting that there was
something not quite right with the mix
now doom executive producer Marty
Stratton has taken to Reddit to set the
record straight
according to Stratton gordon astra
extensions to deadlines which led to the
OST launching after the game as a backup
lead audio engineer Chad must hold it
was asked to develop the OST just in
case Gordon wasn't able to complete his
contributions this ultimately led to the
OST as we know it with roughly a dozen
songs from Gordon and the rest filled in
from moss holder who used game mixes as
he didn't have access to the source
tracks
Gordon allegedly wasn't happy with the
final result so he distanced himself
Stratton has said that he's disappointed
with Gordon's reaction but he wishes him
all the best and said that Gordon won't
be working on the doom eternal DLC it's
currently in development EA made a bunch
of announcements this morning but the
biggest one was that they casually
dropped that EA play would be on
Thursday June 11th it'll be a stream
taking place at 4:00 p.m. Pt but 7 p.m.
ET and while EA hasn't announced which
games it'll be talking about just yet we
can make some educated guesses we'll
probably see more from FIFA Madden and
NHL which have all been confirmed for
this year there's a new battlefield game
in development for next year and a
smaller more unusual Star Wars game
coming from EA motive you can catch the
stream and all the announcements right
here on GameSpot what are you hoping to
see I have all my fingers and toes
crossed for a Mass Effect remaster and
speaking of EA and Star Wars Jedi fallen
order got a free update for Star Wars
day the update includes new combat
challenges and cosmetics for calc Estes
and his adorable droid companion BD 1
and we also finally get new game plus
mode which allows you to replay the
campaign with the unlocked cosmetics and
if that's not enough Star Wars for you
Vader immortal is coming to psvr
this summer Vader immortal is an
episodic Star Wars VR game that
originally launched
the oculus rift and quest last year the
psvr version will include all three
episodes as well as lightsaber dojo
challenges looks like Call of Duty
warzone is coming to next-gen infinity
ward's Taylor Kurosaki told gamer Jen
that the plan is to support warzone for
quote quite some time and this will
include a release for the PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X he said I know that
our plan is warzone is going to be
around for quite some time so as soon as
those new systems are out and available
I'm sure we'll support them and finally
a PSA there'll be no Halo infinite
gameplay on this week's inside Xbox
streamed Microsoft has said that the
series x games showcase on Thursday May
7th will be focusing on global
development partners which means we can
expect to see footage from games like
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and other
third parties but sadly not Xbox is
first party studios like 343 Industries
Xbox marketing executive
Aaron Greenberg confirmed on Twitter
that Microsoft is planning a separate
event to showcase the work of
Microsoft's various Xbox games studios
teams later Greenberg said that
Microsoft has some big summer plans for
showcasing first party titles so I'm sad
we're not gonna see more of infinite it
feels like a lifetime ago since we last
saw that game but I am super excited to
see more from Valhalla make sure to
check back here on GameSpot for all the
latest next-gen gaming news and I'll see
you next time
[Music]